michael is there anything you need from
me i'd like to go back to bed yeah joe
just get some rest to see you monday
unless you're still sick
um
all right we'll have a great long
weekend i'll probably be just
[Laughter]
you enjoyed that didn't you
how old are you going to have kids and
i'm going to get married not necessarily
in that order whatever they're going to
live here what
i love you i love you michael i love you
too what are you even talking about i
was just talking about i farted
are you kidding me i did
oh my god
this is
this is my place okay let's go back to
one hello michael how are you good how
are you good to see you oh sorry there
okay well why don't we just step in what
[Laughter]
he'd enjoy to be fired i don't think he
would tell him really that i am far too
valuable to you
[Laughter]
fire who
i
i
what who is he saying i can't really
make it out
it's fired wyatt you you know what those
are grounds
michael
look at that
[Music]
hey jim hey what's up hey
um i know it's last minute but
i was wondering
[Music]
hey
hey
um i know it's last minute but i was
wondering if it would be
no
that was you
i was wondering if it would be cool
i didn't do anything
i was wondering if it would be cool if i
brought my
oh my god wait
it's casual so i'm not really worried
about numbers or anything cool all right
thanks
nobody even signed my birthday poster
probably because it doesn't even look
like me it's from last year no
[Laughter]
you're making it work
[Laughter]
so see i will end up having your butt in
jail and what they will do to you is
nothing compared to what i'll do to you
before you get down there you are not to
be ready
he said i was dull
i'm not
he said i was dull
i am hoping to find whoever committed
this heinous deed
and i am praying
that i find this
heinous culprit
i will pray to thor himself
[Laughter]
i'm not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am praying
to find the heinous culprit
i am not only hoping to find the culprit
of the saints crime
i am praying
i'm not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am praying
[Laughter]
i am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am praying to find this heinous
culprit
and i will pray
i'm sorry i'm not
okay i can do it
excuse me
we try that again
no it's about my work situation and my
living situation and how they coalesce
into one another because i need a living
situation in order to do my job what
please
[Laughter]
please
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
stanley howard
about vance vance refrigeration
ryan howard
dance dance refrigeration
it's my dad yeah hi um
when should we bring out the cake 1 or 1
30. one's good 1 30.
i'm sorry are we boring you
not phyllis
i see the sales department are down
there they're in the engine room and
they are shoveling coal into the furnace
right
i mean who saw the movie titanic they
were very important in the movie titanic
everyone in the engine room drowned okay
[Laughter]
your ass is on the line mister
so is mine
now i'm gonna ask you again what time
did you go home last night
um six
six
of course
something funny
because you know what millions of people
die every year from drug use
marijuana
leads to crack which leads to crystal
meth
which leads to death
which leads
me
i wanna give you a nappy head because
you're leslie
well that's not your character
where is the clitoris
if
someone says next to the vagina
does that mean
on the leg
what does the female vagina look like
really
sorry
um
my uncle told me it looked like a
sausage casing
i can't work with this
it's too loud what oh we're too loud
we're there anyway
i don't know why i did this
suddenly clearly a different character
literally a whole different guy
it's too loud i can't hear you it's too
loud we're almost there
even though this is a cul-de-sac
i missed my left
knock it off i'm connecting this
interview no that's not what you said
when i came in here you said that i was
conducting the interview now exactly how
much pot did you smoke
uh i want
chili's baby back ribs
[Laughter]
i want my baby back baby
chili's baby back ribs
no wait out the second one okay
[Laughter]
i look forward to drug testing
i used to get a runner's high
which is why now i lift
i look forward to drug testing
but urinating is not something
this is not a joke this is not a
carnival
kind of
[Music]
what it is
nice job nice work
this is busiest
beaver i know it says busiest no no you
screwed that up didn't you
i guess we have to go back don't we
we're wasting a lot of tape give me that
okay
listen
you